i got really fascinated by the way you
read because i thought there was
something wrong with me by doing that
but you you don't really just read a
book to completion you read and then you
pick something else up and you just kind
of go based on your whims whatever
you're interested in well i was raised
by my i was raised by a single mom in
new york and she used the local library
as a daycare center because it was a
very tough neighborhood and so she would
basically say when you get back from
school go straight to the library and
don't come out
until i pick you up late at night so i
used to basically live in the library
and i read everything i read every
magazine i read every pictograph i read
every book or every map i just ran out
of stuff to read i just read everything
so i got over this idea of
that reading a large number of books or
reading a book to completion as a vanity
metric because really
when people are putting up photos on
twitter instagram of look at my pile of
books that i'm reading it's a show-off
thing it's a signaling thing yeah sure
and the reality is i would rather read
the best hundred books over and over
again until i absorb them rather than
read all the books right yeah because
your your brain has finite information
uh in a finite space
you get enough advice it all cancels to
zero
there's a lot of nonsense in books out
there too so
i don't read any more to complete books
i read to satisfy my genuine
intellectual curiosity and it can be
anything it could be nonsense it could
be history it could be fiction it could
be science it could be sci-fi these days
it's mostly sci-fi philosophy science
because that's just what i'm interested
in
but i will read for understanding so a
really good book i will flip through i
won't actually read it consecutively in
order and i won't even just even finish
it i'm looking for ideas things that i
don't understand and when i find
something really interesting i'll
reflect on it i'll research it
and then when i'm bored of it i'll drop
it or i'll flip to another book
thanks to electronic books i've got 50
70 books open at any time in my kindle
or ibooks and i'm just
bouncing around between them
it's also a little bit of a defense
mechanism to how in modern society we
get too much information too quickly and
so our attention spans are very low so
you get twitter you get instagram you
get facebook you're just used to being
bombarded with information so you can
take that to you you can view that as a
negative and be like i have no attention
span or you could view that as a
positive i multitask really well and i
can dig really fast i can if i find a
thread that's interesting i can follow
through five social networks through the
web through the libraries through the
books and i can really get to the bottom
of this thing very quickly it's like the
library of alexandria that i can
research at my disposal so i i no longer
track books read or even care about
books read it's about understanding
concepts
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you